Ähm, was macht eigentlich meine Output?
Ich hab so eine kack Bitrate, weil Junty Media noch nicht umgestellt hat.
Ich vollreue dich, Alter.
Ich überlege gerade, ob ich den Drunner auf ein bisschen niedrigere Auflösung stelle.
Keine Ahnung, ich lasse mal jetzt, ich könnte sogar höher gehen.
Was hast du denn für eine Auflösung eingestellt?
Oh, warte mal, lass mich mal gucken.
Ich glaube bloß 3.5 oder so.
3.6
Was? 3.6 was?
3600 KW... KWS und...
Ach, 3600, das wird übelst pixeln gleich.
Nö, ich hab's gerade an, so schlecht.
Ja, ja, ja, Standbild. Warte mal, wenn sich das bewegt...
Wenn sich das bewegt, dann... dann... wird das übelst, wird das übelst.
Hä, das ist ja kein PC-Game, oder? Ich kann doch noch mal umstellen.
Am Moment, warte mal, du hast ja nur 720p, ne?
No.
Das mach...
Warte mal.
Das mach ich auch, weil ich hab... ich hab 1080.
Ich hab 1000... 1900... nee, warte mal, skaliert auf 1280 mal 720.
Nee, das muss ich auch noch umstellen.
Nicht stumm.
Ah, moin Leute.
Was geht?
Das geht einfach so, warte mal, so scheiße, das kannst du immer noch umstellen.
Warte mal, wo wurscht, ich muss gerade mal kurz hier rescale.
Ich glaub, ich muss das gleich gleich umstellen.
Wir probieren das mal aus.
Leute, also wir probieren das jetzt mal aus, wie es qualimäßig ist.
Und ihr müsst mal gucken, wie es von der Lautstärke her passt.
Willst du jetzt schon starten, oder was?
Was, game?
Hä?
Ja, oder?
Sonst gehen wir noch mal ins Bootcamp und so.
Nee, lass mal kurz warten, bis Twitch und so alles Ankündigungen verschickt hat.
So, Leute, wie ist so die Lautstärke?
Wie ist die Lautstärke von mir?
Wie ist die Lautstärke vom Frasier?
Wann spiel ich eigentlich den Nasier?
Tja.
Come on, Prop.
Zu null.
Na gut.
Du kannst sogar diesen komischen Roboter spielen irgendwie.
Guck mal, ich kann auf diesen Ding switchen.
Warum soll ich den Roboter spielen?
Das ist voll.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du dir dann eins nassen.
Ich hab letztens...
Ich hab bei Dance Gaming reingeguckt und der Roboter stirbt.
Nee, macht er nicht.
Spoiler.
Der Raketenkal hat subscribed.
Dankeschön.
Pock.
Nice.
Leute, ich werd mich heute mal ein bisschen zurückhalten mit übertriebenem Memespam oder
sonst was, weil das ist mir zu viel im Kopf, ne?
Was?
Memespam?
Du meinst auf deine Button smashen oder was?
Ja, das ist mir zu viel.
Mit dir im Discord, in-Game, auf dem anderen Bildschirm, dann irgendwie noch 50 Knöpfe
eh schon drücken müssen.
Das wird zu viel.
Ich mach mal deinen Streamer und mal gucken, wie das bei dir aussieht.
Sonius94.
Nice.
What the fuck?
Wo ist deine Cam?
Nice.
Hier, guck mal, hier hab ich meine Cam.
Oh my god.
Viel zu, viel zu lauen, das Sound.
Bei dir siehts halt wirklich besser aus.
Ja, aber wart mal in Bewegung, wart mal.
Hier, ich geh mal, guck dir das mal an, ich geh mal ins Boot...
Nee, wobei, wenn ich ins Bootcamp geh, müssen die Lobby wieder zu machen.
Also Leute, wir müssen mal gucken, wie die Quali ist.
Es kann sein, dass ich nochmal Stream neu starten muss.
Ihr müsst mir das sagen im Chat dann, ne?
Also, ob ich nochmal Stream neu starten muss.
Ja, mach doch, geh doch nochmal ins Bootcamp.
Bootcamp, dann müssen wir die Party wieder neu machen.
Weil sonst müssen wir uns jetzt erst mal 3 Stunden lang Intro-Videos angucken.
Ja, hast du recht.
Warte mal, ich...
Dann geh ich nämlich auch nochmal raus und gucke mal, ob die Leute auch was hören sollen.
Ich bin mal raus mit dir.
Achso, wir müssen uns da noch kicken?
Nee.
Do you want to bring your squad with you?
No.
Piss dich, Alter.
Geh weg, ey.
So, Bootcamp.
Oh, ich glaub, man spielt ein Grill, kann das sein?
Weil im Hauptmenu ist ein Grill.
I don't know.
Moment, ist das DER Friseur von früher?
Nein, das ist ein anderer.
Der hört sich nur zufällig ja genauso, gehört bloß zufällig genauso an.
Aber das ist ein anderer.
Ja, ich mach gleich noch Twitter-Ankündigungen und...
Das findet wahrscheinlich Ubisoft voll dämlich, ne?
So grad Video hochgeladen für maximal einen Sellout.
Und direkt danach was anderes gepostet, wo die Leute lieber dahin gehen als Video gucken.
Das ist heilig.
Lulwe, Alter, Wub-Lul.
Wie sieht's eigentlich bei dir mit Emotes aus?
Frisilul.
Ich hab sowas nicht.
Ich hab doch nicht immer ein Abo-Button, du...
Okay.
Warte mal, ich mach mal kurz Fullscreen bei mir auf der anderen Seite, wie das aussieht.
Du kannst ja auch mal gucken, wie's bei mir aussieht.
Ja.
Ich mein, der bewegt sich ja noch nicht, der Dude, ne?
Es fehlt die Cam.
Omegalul.
Ich kann die Cam nicht bewegen, das ist...
Tutorial.
Nee, du musst hochgucken, warte.
Jetzt...
Guck mal.
Jetzt klotz hoch.
Reverse.
Du kannst doch ohne...
Ich bin der Einzige auf der Welt, der glaub ich mit Reverse-Control spielt, ne?
Ja.
Vor allem, das war aber standardmäßig eingestellt sogar, ne?
Echt?
Ja, die wissen halt was Gutes, ja.
Als ich...
Als ich angefangen hab, hier in dem Tutorial...
So, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken.
Jetzt pixels wahrscheinlich gleich.
Weil bei mir sieht's gut aus.
Ja, warte mal, warte mal, gleich.
Bei mir sieht's sogar besser aus als bei mir.
Nee, jetzt pixels, guck.
Omegalul.
Jetzt, jetzt pixels, das ist voll.
Na, wobei.
Na, wobei, es nimmt sich nicht so...
Es geht eigentlich, oder?
Ja.
Ich guck jetzt immer kurz ins OBS, ob's irgendwie ruckelt oder so.
Nee?
Passt?
Oh, mir followt jemand.
Ich müsste mal den Follower-Sound, glaube, ausstellen.
Poggu.
Der Osten meldet sich zurück.
Oder einbinden.
Wie mach ich denn das?
Also der Chat sagt, passt alles.
Sieht alles okay aus.
Guck jetzt hier noch mal kurz, wenn ich hier mal einen Kameraschwenk so mache.
Mein Follower-Sound ist halt übelst laut, ne?
Du kannst ja ein bisschen, ein bisschen runter.
Wie machst du denn das?
Ich hab's...
Du kannst ja ein bisschen runter.
Wie machst du denn das?
Mein Follower-Sound ist halt übelst laut, ne?
Du kannst ja ein bisschen, ein bisschen runter.
Wie machst du denn das?
Ich hab's...
Ja, ich glaub, das geht.
Das geht nie.
Was?
Äh doch, du musst...
Was benutzt du für ein Follower-Sound-Ding?
Steamlabs?
Ja.
Dann...
Dann musst du in Steamlabs dich einloggen.
Und da hast du einen Slider.
Geht aber nicht weiter runter, oder?
Warte mal, ich guck mal.
Oh.
Es ruckelt bei dir?
Weil sonst sind die...
Bei mir ruckelt hier überhaupt nicht ruckeln.
Bei mir, also laut OBS ist alles flüssig.
Steamlabs.
Ah.
Gott.
POC.
Okay, mit Twitch.
Out to rising.
Nope.
Und der, der Patrick sagt grad bei dir, dass der hört den Stream-Sound, den Follower-Sound
kaum.
Echt?
Na dann perfekt.
So, dann wäre ich...
Ach, weißt du warum?
Weil ich im OBS ja komplett OBS leise gestellt hab.
Oh Pogu.
So.
Ähm, dann machen wir mal eine Sellout-Message.
Setzen wir mal ab.
Ähm.
Auf...
Machen wir mal Sellout.
Wir machen ein...
Link zu mir.
Äh, ich kann einfach posten.
Du kannst auf Ausrufezeichen, du kannst, bei mir im Chat kannst du Ausrufezeichen-Frisör
machen.
Da gibt's nen, gibt's nen Link.
Zum Originalen.
Nicht zu dem Fake heute.
Ich bin mock bei dir.
Reingestellt.
Ich sag, das passt schon.
Also Leute, sieht alles gut aus, ne?
Kann man so lassen.
Falls es irgendwie übelst, äh später irgendwie übelst ruckelt oder rumpixeln müsst ihr Bescheid
sagen, dann...
Achso, und sagt auch, auf welchem Stream ihr dann seid.
Weil ich hab alle Chats auf, ich blick da grad null durch.
So, wir machen jetzt Sellout-Message.
Also.
Der Frisör.
Ankündigung verschenken.
Ich stremen nun die Gears.
Ich muss mich voll dran gewöhnen, nicht mal, äh, Gears of War zu sagen anstatt, das ist
jetzt ja Gear.
Warum?
Warum eigentlich?
Ich wette, wir würden machen so ne komische, ähm, Beschneidung, sprich...
Beschneidung, ja.
Naja, weil es zu Gewalt...
Guck mal, diese ganzen Sachen früher.
Was ist los, Alderson?
Was ist ab?
Wie siehts bei dir mit Affiliate oder Partner oder so aus?
Könntest du einen Schaum machen.
Die sagen wieder, Alderson sagt schon wieder, du hörst dich genauso an wie ich.
Das ist total dumm, Mann.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Der Frisör und ich stremen nun Gears 5.
Porgas.
Machen wir jetzt Level Up aus, damit wir meinen Follower-Sound rausschmeißen.
Wie kann ich denn das in Steamlabs ausstellen, Max?
Was, den Follower-Sound?
Na?
Die machst du einfach aus, also drehst du auf Null Prozent.
Nee, aber ich hab ja noch im zweiten, in der ersten Scene hab ich den ja auch drin.
Achso.
Verstehst du?
Du kannst das, glaub ich, in den Browser.
Kannst du das in den Browser machen?
Du hast den OBS, musst du den Browser einfügen.
Na, was?
Wurde dann auch die Sachen, weiß ich nicht.
Boah, gute Frage.
Browser, ich lösche das jetzt mal raus.
Ja, dann hast du es in der ersten Scene gar nicht.
Dann lösche ich das einfach bei den Way-Badios am Start, Leute.
Ja, du musst ja abgangeln, ne?
Hier, dann lösche ich das hier einfach mal raus.
Weil das nämlich Double Scene, deshalb hört man das auch.
Mach das, ja.
So, und jetzt mach ich den Maximum-Sellout-Post auf YouTube.
Jetzt sind es Hammerkleifer von den Zuschauern.
Oh, da kann ich immer gucken, ob ich noch angel.
Nice.
Oh, jetzt könnte ich sogar...
Krieg ich Black Desert?
Guck mal, ich kann mir Black Desert über meinen zweiten Bildschirm auf den anderen
Bildschirm ziehen.
Nee, ich hätte jetzt gesagt, du machst Bild in Bild.
Gehst du und angelstreamt.
Wenn euch das zu gewalttätig ist, könnt ihr angelstreamt gucken.
So, jetzt.
Genau, das wäre auch witzig.
Könnte eigentlich mal...
Family Friendly.
Schreibst dir Family Friendly rein.
Aha.
Irgendwie postet das Ding auf YouTube nichts.
Sagt es der Karsten eigentlich immer noch?
Weiß ich nicht.
YouTube?
Leute, ich kann auf YouTube in der Community nichts posten.
Was ist denn da schon wieder los, ha?
A second I call the Lord.
Ah, jetzt geht's.
Alter, ey, wir mal loslegen, ne?
Ja, drei Stunden, ne?
Aber jetzt können wir anfangen.
Ich invite dich, ich invite dich zum...
Zum Porgern.
Das wird gebashed.
Ich gebashed, Alter, jetzt.
So.
Invite.
Ach nee, man muss den komischen anderen...
Ach, würde jemand wissen, ich glaube...
Finn, woher auf immer die Tattoos?
Ja, man geht zum Tätowieren, lässt sich welche machen.
Ich kann dich nicht mehr einladen.
Ha?
Warum nicht?
Weil invite player nicht mehr funktioniert.
Plopp nichts mehr auf bei invite player.
Warte, ich geh ins Menü.
Ne, das liegt nicht an dir.
Weil?
Weiß ich nicht.
Gebarkt.
Gebarkt, ja?
Kann nichts mehr inviteen.
Ich mach jetzt das Game einfach nochmal.
Wie macht man überhaupt Games aus hier?
Game Options.
Quit.
Huge.
So, jetzt aber hoffentlich geht es jetzt.
Sag mal Leute, wer hat sich das eigentlich ausgedacht, ne?
Das komische Xbox-Menü.
Übelst.
Mr.
Crap.
Ist das Game rausgekommen?
Ich lese mal bei dir im Chat mit.
Heute oder?
Gestern.
Ich glaube offiziell heute.
Ne, heute.
Aber gestern konnte es schon.
Ich glaube offiziell heute, ja.
Und übrigens Leute, ganz wichtig, wenn ihr das spielen wollt, egal ob auf Xbox oder PC,
ihr könnt das aktuell für ein Euro spielen.
Ihr müsst einfach einen Xbox, wie heißt der Scheiß, Ultimate Xbox, Ultimate Premium Pass
oder so abschließen.
Der ist gerade 92% reduziert.
Und dann könnt ihr das abschließen.
Direkt cancelen, aber Gears runterladen, weil es inklusive ist.
Das ist huge brain.
Oder du machst wie ich und kostest 70 Euro.
Ich hab das schon gesehen, ne?
Kann man auch machen.
Kann man auch YOLO, Fallfeld.
Aber die Frage ist, kannst du es denn, kannst du es denn unendlich weiter spielen?
Nein, nein, nein.
Also das ist für mich gut zum Kampagnespielen, für dich ist das nicht gut.
Genau.
Weil ich müsste ja jeden Monat.
Du würdest sogar mehr Geld ausgeben.
Genau.
Du würdest dann nämlich noch mal kaufen.
Ja.
Was sagt ihr da?
Äh, Moment.
Moment.
Was?
YouTube.
Was los?
Ich hab mein Streamlink nicht mit kopiert.
Moment.
Scammer.
Was das?
Will YouTube nicht mal, dass man, dass man irgendwelche Sachen...
Wahrscheinlich, dass du keine Werbung mehr machst.
Ey, das wäre, das wäre übelster Fail.
Boah, das wär Pog, da hörste gleich wieder mit YouTube off, ich hab ja gehört.
In deinem Stream, dass du jetzt richter YouTuber wieder bist.
Richtig, ja.
Na.
So.
Na ja.
So Karsten-Style, es wird Geld knapp.
Lol, genau.
Wir verarschen YouTube jetzt, wir pasten das einfach hinten dran, Poggers.
Geh Beitrag erstellen.
Jetzt hat er's, jetzt hat er's richtig, jetzt hat er's kapiert.
Was ist das für ein Game?
Steht oben, Gears of War 5.
Ich hoffe.
Gatze.
Campaign.
New.
Safe.
So, jetzt kann ich nicht hinweiten.
Hoff ich.
Da sieht man mal wieder, dass man mit professionellen YouTubern spielt, weil das dauert dann ewig
immer mal.
Dauert drei Stunden, ja.
Ich weiß noch, früher das alte Xbox-Menü, hast du aufgemacht, hast die Leute eingeklickt
und da wurden sie invited.
Jetzt musstest du selecten und musst dann sagen invite selected people.
Ja.
Gears of War, dann trifft's besser.
Gears of War.
Patrick wieder am Flame, by the way, nice.
Es muss.
So, haste gekriegt.
Invite.
Hallo.
Ha?
Haste Invite gekriegt.
Ach so, gar nicht drauf geachtet, warte.
Ups.
Warte, warte, warte, warte.
Wo war denn das jetzt?
Äh.
Hier, ich glaube hier.
Nee.
Irgendwo im Menü kannst du sagen Freunde oder so?
Ich hab, ich glaube nicht.
Friends?
Ich schick dir einfach noch mal einen.
Warte, warte, ich hab.
Haste?
Okay.
Ich wünsch.
Waiting.
Hast du eigentlich so eine neue Xbox oder noch die alte Xbox?
Ich hab die alte.
Ich hab's auch nicht eingesehen, mir eine neue zu kaufen.
Weil ich mein, wie oft hattest du die an, seit du sie gekauft hast?
Keine Ahnung.
5 Minuten?
Nein, gar nicht.
Okay.
Was spielen wir denn für eine Schwierigkeit?
Irgendwas so mittel, weil wir zacken mit Controllern.
Intermediate.
Experience.
Insane.
Beginner.
Intermediate spielen wir.
Wir müssen ja Insane dann eh nochmal draus spielen.
Ich mach Start.
Jetzt müssen wir uns das Cutscene angucken.
Dann müssen wir die Klappe halten, weil die Leute uns immer sagen, redet nicht immer so
viel in der Cutscene.
Warte, hier fragt noch jemand, wie lange war deine Xbox nicht mehr an?
Na, ich glaube 4 Jahre oder so.
3, 4 Jahre oder so.
Aber hauptsache es ist noch wieder kauf, ne?
Kann ich starten?
Ja.
Bäschen, Alter.
Bäschen.
Jetzt wird's sicher.
Ich glaube, man kann nämlich nicht mehr starten.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Also erst, erst, es wird zersägt.
Aha.
Warum?
Ey, YouTube ist übelst fail, Alter.
Was ist das?
Du kannst, du kannst mittlerweile keine Twitch-Messages mehr gescheit einführen.
Ist übelst reudig, Alter.
YouTube.
YouTube, genau.
Ich fühle mich so richtig Oldschool-Konsole.
Ja, das ist toll.
Ein Headset auf dem Kopf, by the way.
Und übelkrank.
Hallo Jungs und Mädels, hier ist der Max.
Warum habe ich mein Video gerade an?
So, jetzt aber.
Eigene Views pushen in die Dauerschleife oder was?
So, Leute, ihr müsst mal gucken.
Oh nee, jetzt müssen wir die Klappe halten.
Oh, ich hab' die Klappe.
Die spielst auch auf Englisch, oder?
Ja.
Ich check die Gears-Story null mittlerweile.
Einfach bashen.
Oh, das hat gesackt.
Ja.
Du hast den letzten Teil auch nicht gespielt, oder?
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich hab den letzten Teil kaum net gespielt.
Weil ich checke gar nicht, wer die Leute sind.
Ja, ist das.
Das muss sein.
Sag mal, ist das sowas wie was bisher geschah?
Leute, ist das sowas wie was bisher geschah?
Stand am Anfang, am Anfang hab ich den Settings rumgebastelt.
Stimmt, da kann ich mich doch dran erinnern.
Haben wir nicht so einen Typ in irgendeinem Gears da aus gerettet?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
So, bashen.
Bist du noch da?
Jaja, ich bin völlig geflasht.
Ach, das war was im vierten Teil passiert ist.
Weißt du, also wir haben im Prinzip nichts verpasst.
Hast du das nie gespielt, sogar gestreamt?
Den vierten?
Aber nicht mit mir.
Ja.
Ich war's nähe.
Äh.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ne, find ich die Story von Gears eh gar nicht.
Wieso, bist du doof?
Warum, was, was ist alles?
Gears Story Beste einer Aliens?
Wollen die Helmets herrschen?
Ja, das ist das einzig Gute daran.
Hallo?
Ich find.
Ist das Story?
Ich find, wenn ich mir so Leute angucke, irgendwie so wie Markus Phoenix und so, das
ist so der schlechteste Actionheld überhaupt.
Ach, du hast ja keine Ahnung.
Kacknupfen.
Aber, aber Tracer.
Immer haten.
Immer haten, ne?
Ja.
Bei dir fragt jemand, warum kein WoW Classic streamt, Omega Lul?
Wo Classic.
Wenn ich Wo Classic streame, dann mach ich kein YouTube mehr.
Und kein Stream mehr.
Und nix mehr.
Der Composer, der Name kommt mir bekannt vor, ist das nicht der Game of Thrones Typ?
Aber das wisst ihr noch bestimmt, Chet ist schlau, Big Brain Chet.
Decade ist das.
Decade.
Wer ist Decade überhaupt?
Das bist du.
Das bin ich jetzt aktuell, ja.
Das ist der Bert.
Nee.
Oh der Bert, da isser.
Ich will Bert spielen, by the way.
Der Bert ist der Bert Beste.
Vor allem ich hab immer noch Bert als, als mein Profilbild, ne?
Echt?
Stimmt, auf Twitch.
Auf Twitch hast du immer noch den Bert.
Leute habt ihr, jetzt mal ernsthaft, weißt du wer das ist?
Ist Decade hier?
Ja.
Ich weiß gar nicht wer hier was ist.
Ich auch nicht, ich kenn bloß den Typ.
Wobei die ist nach einem Judgement auch gewesen.
Ist die das?
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Was soll denn da losgehen hier?
Welchen, Alter?
Ich will, ich will sägen.
Du kriegst wahrscheinlich eh nur so ne komische Startpistole.
Kannst erst mal nix sägen.
Oh jetzt, Slate, Slate.
I Freezie Left The Game steht da grade da.
Läufts von dir weiter?
Nö, bei mir lädt's.
Oh Gott.
Ah man.
Xbox, Alter.
Wer weiß was es ist.
Ich lad dich gleich wieder an.
Ich hab dich gekickt, oder was?
Ne.
Ich invite dich sobald die komische Cutscene hier vorbei ist.
Ich hoffe wir müssen nicht nochmal starten und es nochmal angucken.
Wir gucken jetzt einfach bei dir.
Ist der Friseur eigentlich noch Friseur?
Ne.
Alter sag dich, ich will bashen.
Ja, es läuft eh noch die Zwischensequenz.
So fail, dass du gleich rausfließt hast.
Jetzt wird sich erstmal abgezahlt.
Okay.
Ich guck bei dir an.
So, ich jetzt invite dich mal.
Game Options.
Fuck, ich weiß gar nicht wie das geht.
Was?
Ich muss RT drücken.
Komm invite mich.
RT, ja.
Hi Frise, select, invite.
Hast du gekriegt?
Aber du bist schon in dem Game, oder was?
Ja, in dem wo wir gerade gestartet haben.
Ja perfekt, da haben wir gar nicht viel gepasst, außer dass wir uns abseilen.
Ich bleibe jetzt beim Abseilen hängen, bis du gejoint bist.
Kannste joinen?
Ja, ich machs was.
Ich bin da.
Okay, slide ist grad runter.
Und jetzt Synchronizing, blablabla.
Nee, ich muss jetzt hier irgendwie 20 Sekunden warten.
Okay, ich warte bis du wieder in-game bist.
Kann man das auf PC zocken, ja?
Für ein Euro gerade.
Aber ich hab mal gehört, dass es mit Absetzen aktuell jetzt so rare ist.
Okay.
Aber Connection Loss wäre schon fail.
Okay, es lädt.
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt.
Frise, enter the game.
Oh, toll.
Ich will nicht, dass es lädt.
Wie ging das weiter?
Weil wenn es lädt...
Dann dauert es immer so lange.
Warte, ich dann stürzt es ab oder sowas?
Nee, dann dauert es immer so lange.
Dann dauert es so lange, irgendwie so.
Übrigens, man seilt sich auch ab, wenn man nach oben drückt.
Das ist nicht Immersive.
Oh, jetzt, ich seile.
Du seilst, wo bist du?
Ich seh dich nicht seilen.
Du musst seilen.
Ich komm runter, Dude.
Ich seh dich nicht.
Wo bin ich geseilt?
Ich bin unterwegs.
Ach, du bist schon runter geseilt.
Unter mir geseilt.
Ich seile gerade.
Ja, ja.
Seh dich.
Seh dich seilen.
Vor allem bei mir passt es auch, ne?
Wenn abseilen.
By the way.
You know what I mean.
Ich hab die passenden Emails für alles im Streben.
Ach guck mal, jetzt ist die Sensitivity okay.
Komisch.
Merkwürdige Zeichen.
Okay, A gedruckt halten war rennbar, Gears.
Genau.
So, da ist der geile Phoenix.
Da bist du.
Ja, ich seh das.
Ich bin das.
Genau, man kann.
Das ist die Kate.
Aber man kann nicht.
Ich muss mal gucken, wegen Controller-Settings.
Und das ist Dave.
Dave, das fliegt da oben.
Oh.
Der ist.
Sag mal, wenn du ready bist mit Settings.
Ja, du.
Nee, ich hab gar nichts.
Ich hab gar nichts.
Okay.
Wow, ich kann.
Jump.
Warum move ich so dumm?
Und du hinter dir.
Weißt du was?
Hallo?
Kannst nicht.
Also du kannst.
Also ich kann nur mit A springen.
Kannst du auch mit A springen?
Nee.
Weil ich kann auch nicht schnell rennen.
Ey, warum läuft der so dumm?
Slider-End kann ich machen.
Ja, das ist auch das einzige, was ich machen kann.
Der läuft nicht.
pathetic.
IDS ist das einzige, was ich machen kann.
Der läuft nicht schnell.
So jetzt.
Ach so.
Okay, okay.
Dann ist es defined.
Story-Intro-Sequenz.
Aber sieht schon gut us im Vergleich zu den alten Gears.
Aber gut die haben auch eine Hardware, die stopplet so schnell, ne also.
Ja.
Boom!
Check mal, ob Teamkill an ist.
Nee.
etasche echt.
Mein Aim ist richtig sauber, ey!
Ich glaub mir auch, mein Aim ist auch voll im Arsch!
Ein-zutreffen!
Ich glaub ich bin schon leer, bevor überhaupt jeder kommt, by the way!
Wir brauchen kein Intro!
Wir rennen jetzt einfach hier lang!
Das Game will nicht, dass wir hier lang rennen!
Es will Cinematic machen!
Doch, du kannst mit den Prime Sub-Emotes verwenden, klar!
Muss vielleicht mal refreshen!
Also, halb so große Pläne sind ein bisschen die Spezialität von Baird!
Mein Vater?
Bevor er sterb, ließ Baird in ein paar Kog-Segrets.
Und auf dieser Isle gibt es viele von ihnen!
Ah, jetzt kann man den Dave da hinschicken!
Okay, Dave!
Mach mal!
Geiler Flieger-End hier, der Dave!
Grenade?
Da haben wir weggecrapped!
Ich stell' den mal vor, der Karsten wird jetzt mitspielen!
Die Granate, die wäre noch nicht mal über den Abgrund drüber!
Da wären die schon weg!
Doch, guck mal, da ist noch Ammo!
Kannst du Ammo aufnehmen?
Wenn du das aufnimmst, ist es dann weg?
Ah, nein!
Doch!
Kein Custom Loot!
Ich muss mal in den Options ganz kurz gucken!
Neuer Controller!
Frag mich, ob das auf der Xbox...
Äh, wie heißt das?
X?
S?
Ne, X!
Also die neue, die schnellere!
Ob das da viel besser aussieht, oder ob es kaum Unterschiede gibt!
Keine Ahnung!
Oh, da liegt was!
Okay, jetzt kann ich rennen!
Was hier?
Geiles Coaster!
Oh, man weiß noch, wo wir in Gears 1 Achievements gemacht haben!
Ne, das müssen wir hier wahrscheinlich auch machen!
Und wo wir...
Nein, wir sind mittler... Oh, oh, guck mal! Sägen!
Hier, für dich! Säge!
Was? Säge, du darfst sägen!
Alter, yes!
R&B!
Säge M!
Variety Twitch Prime, Dankeschön!
Ich will aber Leute zersägen und nie diese Dinger hier!
Ja, das kommt vielleicht noch!
Man weiß noch, in Gears 1, wo wir das erste Poster übersehen haben
und 3 Stunden oder 3 Tage oder so gesucht haben!
Cinematic, 30 FPS!
Fabi Gangster hat subscribt!
Danke! Nice!
Oh, wir dürfen richtig laufen!
Wir dürfen richtig laufen! Nice!
Oh, da sind Gegner!
Direkt neben uns!
Oh, ich seh es, lol!
Warte mal, A, A, Cover, Cover!
Ja, so ging das, genau!
Wie die Kacknupfen, wie die größten Scheißnupfen!
Konnte man nicht irgendwie ranzoomen mit RT, LT?
Ne, gell? Oder?
Alter, ich bin die Shotgun!
Oh, geil, wir haben die Shotgun!
Nein!
Hab ich jetzt irgendwas geworfen?
Ok, ich bin der Übelste!
Oha, fuck, das sind meine!
Alter, ich hab die Steuerung null drauf!
Die werden gebashed!
Aber eigentlich ist das richtig Oldschool, ne?
Weil das erste Game, das wir richtig gesucht haben, Co-op auf der 360, war Gears 4.1!
Weißt du noch?
Und wo ich da quasi nach dem dritten Mal durchspielen ungefähr den Controller benutzen konnte!
Die matchen gar nicht mehr richtig!
Hast du Gore an?
Muss man das looten oder looted man automatisch?
Ah ne, hier!
Irgendwie stimmt meine Steuerung noch nicht!
Zoomst du ran, wenn du RT drückst?
Ja?
Echt? Schnell!
Passt du mal dran, wenn ich RT...
Was hast du denn eingestellt?
Default!
Ich stell dir jetzt an, was hast du Classic?
Hast du gerade eingehalten oder was?
Was hast du eigentlich eingestellt? Classic?
Nee, Classic alt?
Classic, ne?
Classic alt?
Aber das stimmt nicht so ganz!
Nee, das zoomt nicht ran, wenn du RT drückst!
Ich bleib jetzt auf Default!
Das passt glaube ich noch am besten!
Wo bist du hin? Da!
Hier durch?
Ah, hier muss man lang!
Das Game ist jetzt auch für PCR!
Ja!
Warum machst du das nicht?
Warum musst du das die Kate machen?
Ich war gerade weit weg!
Ich glaub das Game will, dass die Kate das macht!
Die müssen uns zeigen, dass wir Frauengitter heben können!
Monka Toss!
Warum spielen die Xbox aus Nostalgiegründen?
Nee!
Warum spielen wir noch mal Xbox?
Weil Gears Xbox gehen muss!
Ach, weil Multiplayer und so, ne?
Ja, wegen Multiplayer. Du kannst doch auf dem PC Gears zocken, aber...
Vielleicht ist es ja sogar Crossplay!
Ok, Active Reload klappt schon mal!
So muss es sein!
Oh, jetzt wird er gebashed!
Bam!
Bashed!
Jawoll!
So ist das gut!
Huge Bash!
Oh, Shotgun!
Shotgun!
Ok, ich seh gerade, ne?
Du kannst die nicht direkt umwerfen!
Oh, ich hab keine Muni mehr!
Oh, mein Huge Aim mit dem Controller!
So geht es genauso!
So, jetzt kommt Shotgun hier raus!
Bam!
So muss es sein!
Erstmal schön looten!
Lebt hier noch was?
Da!
Jetzt kommen wir hier bashen leider!
Guck mal, ich hab ihn gerade als Schutz!
Den kann man da auch zack!
So ist das gut!
Alles muss gebashed werden!
Du musst looten noch!
Soll ich auf den?
Oder hast du genug Ammo?
Ne, ein Asher hab ich schon genug!
Stimmt, du spielst ja Shotgun auch nie, ne?
Ne, hier kann ich nie!
Die rennen schneller als in den alten Games!
Ne, die rennen langsamer!
Der flitzt voller Flitzer!
Das Handling nach Left Right
ist nicht mehr so klobig, aber
rennmäßig finde ich irgendwie langsamer!
Ich finde, der flitzt voller!
Oh, wo ist Segen?
Weiß ich gar nicht, wo du bist!
Ach, da!
Ach, hier das komische Ding!
Segen, Segen, RB!
Krasser Reger!
Das ist aber nur Kabelsägen!
Kabelsägen ist...low!
Vielleicht kann ich dich gleich sehen!
Ja!
Schließt die Mausentastatur in die Xbox an!
Stop, das geht bei dem Game nicht!
Echt?
Anzugloppen machen!
Das ist ja grad das Sinn
bei Gears, dass du mit dem Controller
spielst, weil das Setting
zumindest war es früher so, selbst auf dem PC
mit dem Controller einfach smoother ist!
Gerade wenn du so um die Ecken
stellst! Also, so wie ich gerade mit dem Controller
spiele, ist es ja grad nicht smoother!
Warum spielst du auf Englisch?
Äh...
Weil, weil...
Ich sag nur so!
In dein Gesicht zur Hölle ja!
Genau, das reicht schon!
Guck mal, ich bin Bouncing!
Bouncing Queen!
Multiplayer geht ab!
Oh, ach, Ink!
Vor allem Ink, ja!
Huge Controller, ey!
Alter, ich geh da jetzt rein hier!
Nasher?
Der Nasher basht!
Ich war jetzt mit Active Reload
in deinem Gesicht!
In deinem Gesicht!
Und her, die dreckigen!
Alter!
Wow, explodieren die?
Das könnte sogar sein, dass die explodieren!
Ich glaub, die explodieren!
Muss Shotgun, Shotgun!
Baschen!
Shotgun, Active Reload, Baschen, Alter!
Bam! Next!
Bam! Oh, fuck!
Der hat grad schon Damage gemacht gerade!
Der hat die explodieren!
Da muss man nicht aufpassen!
Hatte man nicht immer so ein
Gears-Logo sonst im...
Ah, hier, ich hab' Pissed-Logo!
Hatte man nicht immer so ein
Gears-Logo in der Mitte, womit man
gut Shotguns heilen kann?
Nee, ich glaub' erst mal
mit Multiplayer oder so!
Alter, Headshot!
Baschen!
Wo wird gesägt?
Kann man den sägen?
Stimmt!
Oh, da gibt's Loot!
Bam!
Active Reload, zack!
Oh, ich hab' Reload bekommen!
Da kommen ganz schön viele gerade!
Das werden ein bisschen viele, oder?
Geht schon!
Ah, jetzt!
Oh mein Controller, ey!
Alter, das ist auch schlecht!
Ich treffe überhaupt nichts!
Gibt's hier Loot?
Irgendwo ein bisschen Ammo oder so?
Ah, hier, guck mal!
Damit du schon mal den Shotgun dagegen austauschen!
Will ich das denn?
Ja, komm!
Hab' ich das weggecrapped grad?
Nee, nee! Du kannst doch nie die Shotgun!
Alter, Shotgun ist das Beste!
Da gibt's bestimmt einfach
in jeder Ecke neue Shotgun!
Du musst dir bloß mal eine Shotgun
anliegen lassen, wenn's wieder eine gibt!
Hier gibt's Säge-Action!
Nee, der Dave! Der Dave muss was machen!
Oh, Dave!
Der Retro-Lancer
ist nicht mal hier so vor eins gewesen!
Warum, wie kann der dann Retro sein?
Big brain!
Jetzt wird geslided!
Alter, ich will mitsliden!
Du hast dich runterteleportiert!
Ammo!
Guck mal, da gibt's eine
Hammer-Burst!
Braucht keiner!
Das ist diese Locust-Crab-Waffe, oder?
Das müssen wir an ihr machen!
Mr. Doxor!
Alter, was muss ich machen?
Ich hab' keine Ahnung!
Warte, wir müssten den Dave fragen, wahrscheinlich!
Wie ging das hier?
Hier einfach X drücken!
Einfach angucken und X drücken!
Das sind die anderen Dudes!
Alter, ich will auch hier...
Hey, lustig!
Das war eine Stels-Mission!
Ja, egal! Warum?
Die wirkliche Stels!
Wo Lull, Alter!
Oh, jetzt war mal eine Granate, jawoll!
Das war nicht meine Frag!
Meine Frag ist vorne zu Füßen gelandet!
Da ist nichts passiert!
Ich glaub, da vorne steht so ein Boom-Shot!
Nimm mal das fette Ding!
Sag mal, kannst du ranzoomen mit RT?
Also, ich mein...
Nee, nee, nee, ich mein mit dem Stick!
Nicht mit RT! Ich laber dummes Zeug!
Von links, links, links!
Ich seh' bei dir!
Ich retz dich, ich retz dich!
Genau, komm!
Du musst schneller, du musst schnell zu mir!
Du sterbest!
Was muss ich drücken? X!
Man hat's gar nicht gesehen!
Wie viel war denn das?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Timer hat oder so!
Das war einfach ein bisschen Panik gemacht!
Nee, es gab nen Timer!
Hier ist ein Granatenwerfer!
Achtung, Granatwerfer!
Huge!
Damn!
Jawoll!
So muss das sein!
Hier, hier liegen noch Granaten rum!
Hier ist so ein Retrolenser hier!
Hammer-Burst will keiner!
Was ist denn das? Kann man hier runter?
Oh, da kommt was vor uns!
Der Retrolenser passiert ja so nach oben!
Den muss man zertreten, den Wut hier!
Ich nehm' doch mal Hammer-Burst!
Ja!
Nice!
Schön Sego aus!
Oh, das ist so nice, wie die platzen!
Oh, ich glaub' ich hab' gerade Friendly-Fire!
Gibt's Friendly-Fire?
Weiß ich nicht!
Die nehmen auch gar nicht so viel Damage, wenn man rangeht!
Ja, ist geiler, wie beim Multiplayer!
Oh, Huge-Aim wieder!
Komm' jetzt, Shotgun!
Ah, ich hab' gar keine Shotgun mehr!
Ist hinter uns gewesen?
Nee!
Komm, Ypsilon! Der Dave! Der Dave muss pulsen!
Jawoll!
Dave hat gepulst!
So! Achtung! Achtung!
Jetzt!
Bam!
Ich glaub', ich bin zu weit!
Oh Gott!
Wo bist du?
Der ist gerade gebombt!
Was?
Bist du auch da?
Naja!
Das Ding hält ganz schön viel aus!
Ich hab' gar keine Bombe!
Alter, warum hält das so viel aus?
Ich bin down!
Alter, Alter, Alter!
Oh! Ah!
Ich bin auch zu Lava-Scheiß oder so!
Ja, ich...
Ich glaub', ich hab' einfach noch nicht gecheckt!
Ach so, drück ganz schnell A!
Ich weiß nicht, ob das noch geht, wie früher!
Oh, wo bist du denn?
Ich kann da nicht hoch!
Da kann man nicht mehr hoch!
Zagt, Alter!
Oh Gott!
Oh nee!
Bist du gestorben, oder was?
Okay!
Ah, okay!
Ich sterb' dann!
Also, der Chat sagt einfach reinballern!
Er nimmt 2012 da in Erfindens-1, einfach reinballern!
Also, typische Gears-Taktik!
Nee, die Fliegevieche,
das soll man noch schießen!
Was irgendwie logisch erscheint,
weil die haben dieses Lava-Scheiß da!
Die Fliegevieche, ja, und dann das fette Viech, ne?
Ja!
Wir machen jetzt erstmal die
kleinen Clear, bevor wir da runterhüppen!
Das ist geil, wie man in ein paar Jahren so zum absoluten Aim Kacknup werden kann, ne?
Oft im Controller.
Ich weiß nicht, was ist das hier, was ist da?
Aber guck mal, jetzt kann man den Dave da hinschicken, der holt da etwas.
Alter, ich hau dir einfach die Dinger in die Nase.
Ich boomshot den Typ einfach, fam.
Guck mal, der hat damage gekriegt, aber nicht viel, ne?
Muss man da vielleicht von hinten drauf schießen?
Das ist doch vielleicht so ne Gears-Taktik, wo man von hinten drauf schießen muss.
Ich geh mal hinter den, guck mal, ob man da von hinten drauf schießen muss.
Guck mal, ob du von hinten drauf ballern kannst.
Hatt ich auch so ein kleines, wie ich getroffen?
Ja, einfach drauf ballern.
Ok, guck mal, ob das mit von hinten funktioniert.
Kappa Pryde.
Nee, Storm-Shop-Toner-Sheet.
Oh fuck, guck mal, da kommt noch mehr.
Warum macht das so viel Damage?
Ach, der hat jetzt so... was ist das denn für ein Viech?
Ich dachte erst, es ist ein Gegner.
Erstmal looten.
Der Gegner irgendwie...
Da ist ne Ammo-Kürbischt.
Oh, die laufen immer so.
Irgendwie hab ich meine Steuerung noch nicht so richtig.
Irgendwie hat mich Gears-Dingens...
Ich bin übrigens...
...durchschnittlich nicht voll versaut.
Ich bin übrigens voll dämlich, ne, dass mit dem RT, also mit dem, ich meine gar nicht
RT, mit dem rechten Stick, ranzoomen, das war Uncharted.
Das war gar nicht, ähm, war gar nicht, ähm, wie es zuvor.
Uncharted konntest du ranzoomen und noch ein Stück ranzoomen.
Ach, wo geht's lang?
Das war aus, ja?
Ja.
Lol, der Frasier, den gibt's noch, ja?
Der streamt auch.
Mach mal Ausrufezeichen Friseur oder Ausrufezeichen Friesi.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Dann gibt's, äh, Chat, den Channel.
Wo ist der Dave?
Der Dave muss das jetzt machen.
Dave, komm!
Ich glaub, wir sollen da außen rumlaufen.
Ich glaub, wir sollen da außen rumstelzen.
Wenn Ausrufe...
Nee, du kannst doch den Dave dort rein schicken, in diesen komischen...
Echt?
Ich dachte, vielleicht irgendwie.
Ich glaub, man muss da außen rumlaufen.
Busy mit Ypsilon.
Ah, es ist, ich hab's.
Echt?
Hier kann man nämlich schon außen rumlaufen.
Du musst da einfach nur aimen und dann kommt der Typ.
Dann stellt er dich rein.
Big Brain.
Oh, ich bin wieder da.
Ey, Dilly can't backseat gaming, dude.
Wir haben uns immer über so Leute lustig gemacht, ne?
Die let's playen und nicht spielen können.
Oder?
Ist doch so.
Aber ich sag dir, in spätestens zwei Missionen gehen wir wieder ab.
Easy.
Hier.
Retro Lancer.
Alter, ich hab meine Nähe schon getroppt.
Nein!
Schaut, kein Crap.
Der Karsten hätte es gekrappt.
Easy.
Hammer Burst.
Hier hälst du bestimmt noch irgendwelches Stellzeug zum Sammeln.
Garantiert.
Aber wie ist das?
Bist du noch irgendwie auf Achievement sammeln oder so?
Nee, aber außer bei Gears hab ich eigentlich immer versucht, alles komplett zu machen.
Was?
Oh, ein Cocktail.
Alter, es gibt noch Cocks.
Cocktags.
Na, hier ist richtig viel.
Brauchst du noch andere oder so?
Macht der Dave für dich auch Licht oder macht er nur bei mir Licht?
Ich glaub der Dave macht nur bei mir Licht.
Wo ist denn der?
Nö, der hat hier Licht.
Der macht für mich auch Licht.
Ja gut, jetzt sind wir auch zusammen.
So, wo muss man lang?
Da oben.
Was ist das eigentlich für ein Fisch?
Okay, wir ballern uns mal nicht weiter an.
Ich bin wieder Karsten, immer nur am Zeug looten.
Open Ball Talk, ihr Beste.
Hier gibt's auch noch was zu looten.
Oh, 3,33%.
Ich hab jetzt deine Snub gelootet.
Ja, gönn dir.
Okay, wo geht's lang?
Dave, pulse mal.
Wenn man Speedrun.
Da.
Checkpoint, warte.
Ups.
Hier.
Ich bin schon durchgelaufen.
Bist du da?
Ah, man kann diese roten Fässer also anschießen.
Irgendjemand ist verreckt.
Ich brauch' Nate reinschmeißen.
Oh Dave, Dave, lebt der noch?
So, die gehen alle auf Dave oder was?
Oh mein Controller, ey.
Zu mehr Damage, also wenn man auf den Kopf zielt, ist mehr Damage.
Ja, das dachte ich mir schon, wenn ich das schaffen würde, auf den Kopf zu zielen.
Was haben wir denn hier liegen?
Oh, Schneiber.
Nee, Minigun, nicht Schneiber.
Okay, das kann man...
Ich kann vor allem hier, ich kann mit dem Ding nichts gescheit machen.
Aber jetzt werden sie weggestellt, da oben.
Oder auch nicht.
Ja, weg, wegstellen.
Der LMG.
Der LMG sackt über Range.
Der Huge sackt.
Komm hier in die Dore.
Er wird jetzt herangestellt, herangestellt, dann wird er gesprayt.
Ich muss mal Waffe wechseln, das sackt total mit dem Ding.
M.
X.
Gehen wir mal ran.
Oh, Header.
Hast du mir Header gegeben?
Da gab's nen Header.
Richtig, richtiger Header.
Ich hab' den Header.
Warte mal, ich muss mal hier noch den Nebenraum erstellen.
Ich muss auch noch mal looten, ne Runde.
Her gibt's irgendwas.
Kann man hier nicht runterhüpfen?
Was ist das für ein Blödsinn?
Collectible.
Collected.
Weißt du, wie geil das auf der 360 war, diese ganze Achievement-Geschichte?
Ja.
Weißt du auch, wo wir dieses komische Avatar-Game extra gekauft haben für Achievements?
Kennst du das noch?
Wir haben damals, Leute, wir haben damals so ein komisches...
Was war das hier?
Avatar...
Jaja, irgendwie so ein Avatar-Game gekauft.
Weil, dann konnte man tausend Gamerscores machen in den ersten zwei Minuten.
Du musstest einfach am Start stehen bleiben.
Und immer die gleiche Taste drücken.
Welchen Schwierigkeit-Scratch zocken wir?
Mittel.
Weil wir zacken.
Du hast Mittel, ja?
Ja.
Ganz schön schwer auf Mittel, ne?
Früher hätten wir uns da übelst immer weggeholt und weggepistelt.
Ja, haben wir die sonst immer gleich auf Internet gefahren.
Wir haben immer auf Mörgsten gespielt dann.
Also außer des allerersten Gears.
Wir zacken einfach nur.
Wir sind mittlerweile schlecht.
Wo müssen wir jetzt hin machen?
Dave, lass Dave pulsen.
Wir sind so schlecht.
Du kannst Dave da rein... checken.
Du kannst Dave hier irgendwie rein schicken, glaub ich.
Da oben oder wo? Ach hier, gucke mal.
Wo denn?
Man muss aimen und dann muss man Körbe X drücken.
Zack.
Da stehe.
So, Baird hat once lost Theta, ne? Was sieht das denn aus?
Na, wenn man sich anpultet...
Ich laufe irgendwie so ein bisschen ungelenkig gerade mit dem Ding, oder?
Ich bin erstmal reinge-dashed.
Irgendwie...
Ja, no.
Vielleicht haben sie die Steuerung einfach ein bisschen anders gemacht.
Nee, ist das nicht die Richtige. Man kann ja anpacken.
Okay.
So, was haben wir denn hier?
Zeugs, Loot.
Oh.
Sind die durchgelesen, Maxis?
Ja.
Das war ein Comment vom Frosch, der hat geschrieben...
Aber Ackle.
Kennst du denn noch den Frosch?
Was? Welchen Frosch?
Da gab es doch auf YouTube den Typ...
Jett, kennt ihr den Frosch noch?
Der hat auf YouTube immer unter jedes Video geschrieben, aber Ackle.
Oder aber Ekle.
Irgendwie sowas.
Jetzt habe ich dieses komische Ding.
Ja, ich wollte es, aber ich habe es weggeschmissen.
Guck mal, hier kann man bestimmt jetzt...
Ah, ups.
Was ist das? Ist das so eine Flex, oder?
Guck mal, jetzt ist das dort oben gestackt.
I don't know.
Ach.
Okay, Dave, wo müssen wir hin?
Hier ist ein Save, hier muss er hin.
Der Dave.
Dave ist praktisch, oder?
Dave ist praktisch, was der alles kann.
Naja, aber Dave sagt irgendwie immer, den Dave...
Ja, ich finde es auch viel besser, du gehst, hindrückst, ehe reißt den Save auf und gut ist.
Du meinst bestimmt wieder Daven, oder?
Bestimmt.
Na klar, es ist ja immer nur Daven.
Ich wette, mit dem der Roboter stirbt.
Weil die bauen den so auf, weißt du?
Alter, jetzt gebe ich den voll.
Ach so, wir müssen zusammen.
Gibst du dem Dick in die...
Ich weiß nicht, ob man das sagen darf auf Twitch.
Ich kenne nur die Leute, die beim 20.000 Abos-Special dabei waren.
Hier liegt viel Zeug rum.
Oh hier, guck mal, eine Boomshot, die kannst du dir gönnen.
Ja, besser als der Hammer Burst.
Du bist mit diesem fetten Ding da und...
Ist das hier was? Ist das was zum Werfen?
Alle, das ist Boomshot-Ammo und...
Guck mal, da sind noch welche, oder?
Da wird jetzt reingeboomshotted, pass mal auf.
Bam.
So, das kommt runter hier.
Wird schreckt.
Kommt mir nicht runter.
Sieh, das ist echt komisch.
Oh, da ist auch noch mehr mit der Boomshot.
Moment, wie kommt man hier runter?
Ach, einfach runterlaufen.
Big Brain.
Der wird jetzt counterboomshotted.
Wie der...
Da sind uns noch drin.
Warum lebt denn der noch?
Alter.
Au.
Alter, mein Aim, das kriegt nix geschissen auf der X.
Jetzt aber.
Ich glaube, der hält einfach nur viel aus.
Hier siehst du den Lebensbalken hast du auch darüber.
Ja, ja.
Aber ich dachte eigentlich, früher sind die auch die fettesten Gegner bei einem Boomshot-Treffer gesplattered.
Meine Güte.
Das ist eine Granate voll in die Fresse.
Ich hab' ein bisschen das Problem, dass ich manchmal nicht sehe, was jetzt hier Gegner und was nie ist.
Oh.
Aber jetzt hier ist auch ein Boomshot.
Ach guck mal, Dave, mach noch was.
Der elektrisiert die...
Die Gegners.
Wir werden geschockt.
Funktioniert die noch?
Ja.
Okay, funktioniert die Waffe eigentlich?
Bist du schon dran gewöhnt, aktiv zu reloaden?
Hm?
Bist du schon gewöhnt, so aktiv reload zu machen und immer zur richtigen Zeit zu drücken?
Das kann ich noch ein bisschen, aber...
Erst das zum Beispiel.
Das kann ich nur mit einem Nashorino.
Früher, ich weiß noch, wo ich Ultimate Edition gezockt hab', da konnte ich das sogar drücken, ohne hinzugucken.
Ich glaub', wir müssen die Eier erstmal kaputt machen.
Da kommt bestimmt was raus, wenn wir die Eier nicht kaputt machen.
Früher haben die aber auch was gesagt, wenn du aktiv reload getroffen hast.
Ja, ja.
Jetzt sagen die gar nichts mehr.
Da weiß der gar nicht, ne?
Du musst immer oben rechts in die Ecke kloppen, das ist übelst dämlich.
Oh, bin ich dumm, Alter.
Wo geht's denn weiter?
Lass mal, Dave ping.
Nee, die sagen nix mehr.
Nee, die sind etwas doof.
Aber wo geht's denn lang?
Ach, da, da.
Da muss man Dave, Dave, Dave hinchecken wieder.
Oder auch nicht.
Hast du?
Nö.
Aber ich glaube, wir können einfach irgendwie hin.
Na, guck mal, da, da kann man...
Das ist...
Hä?
Big brain, small brain.
Zu klein.
Hier, warte mal, hier war da gerade so ein Y-Ding.
Echt?
Wo?
So.
Hä?
Kriegst du alles angezeigt, wenn es geht, aber man schickt den einfach da rüber?
Nee, ist halt so.
Vielleicht müssen wir...
Na ja, wissen wir ja.
Vielleicht müssen wir da wieder rein.
Ich glaube, wir müssen wieder in den Raum zurück und dann Dave irgendwelche Dinger machen lassen.
Ja.
Gut.
Weil die stehen, weil die anderen NPCs stehen da aus,
auch drinne rum.
Hier, guck mal.
Hier.
Warum kann das eigentlich nur Dave machen?
Warum kann ich da nicht draufdrücken?
Nee, das könnt ihr machen.
Die Stimme vom Friseur ist wie vor neun Jahren.
Na, wir sind ja auch beide schon aus dem Stimmbruch gewesen, als wir YouTube angefangen haben.
Wobei...
Manche sagen ja noch nie so richtig.
Der Bert.
Hat der Friseur auch einen Twitch-Kanal, ja?
Aber normalerweise spielen da so komisches Asia-Krinder-Zeug.
Hä?
Was hieß komisch?
Ist doch...
Gehen ist voll gut.
Für die meisten Leute ist das komisch.
Jetzt müssen wir...
Jetzt sind wir wieder getrennt, oder?
Weiß ich nicht.
Sind wir zu nebeneinander, ne?
Das war im ersten Nubels schwer auf schwer, ne?
Kennste, wo man diese Zehnten, wo man getrennt kämpfen musste und dann einer gestorben ist,
war man down?
Ja.
Alter, bei mir ist hier jemand schon wieder.
Hä?
Der andere Seite sind welche.
Ich wurde wieder seitlich geklaut.
Die waren Nubels der Marke.
Na, ihr müsst Ausrufezeichen Frisien machen, auf alles klein gestehen.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man damit spielt, mit dem Teil.
Achso, okay.
Acht, so ging das ja in Giers.
Du konntest ja hier so von Cover zu Cover stellzen, ne?
Ja.
Jetzt check ich's...
Langsam check ich's wieder.
Ja, so ging das, genau.
Komm, da können wir nicht drüber mit dem Teil.
Muss Dave.
Dave kann das alles.
Nee.
Geht nicht.
Gut, Dave.
Guck da, da kann man Dave schon hinschicken, hier.
Du machst das schon mit dem Dave.
Dave fackelt die gerade ab.
Ach, da hinten sind noch welche.
Bis ich irgendwann losgetroffen werde.
Ja, wir müssen jetzt noch irgendwie für die andere Raketenseite starten.
Wir müssen halt nur checken.
Ich hab jetzt X gedrückt, irgendwas hat's gemacht.
Da ist Dave, der hat jetzt den Robber dahingeschickt.
Ich hör, wir über uns sind, eure Deutsche.
Nee, auf der anderen Seite ist noch einer.
Ich geh gar nicht davon, dass ich geholfen werde.
Kann man den segen?
Oh fuck, fuck, ich verrecke.
Ich wollte den segen und das ging nicht.
Halt.
Warte.
Alter, ich...
Wie er rumslided.
Ja, der wird gebashed.
Bei mir war es X.
Wo ist denn der?
Ach, dort.
Erstmal auf Ende des Games haben wir wieder das übelste Xbox Aim und dann spielen wir
auf der Xbox Modern Warfare.
Nee, ich hab mir noch so einen komischen Adapter gekauft, wo du Tastatoren schließen kannst.
Das ist eigentlich richtig cheat, wenn du es so willst.
So, okay.
Dave, wo geht's lang?
Da drüben wahrscheinlich.
Doch, wir hätten die gar nicht killen müssen.
Wir hätten die einfach die Rakete einschalten müssen.
Easy.
Braucht man irgendwie Muni hier, oder?
Kann man jetzt hier hoch?
Nee.
Ah, hier.
Alter.
Ja, oh, der muss gebashed werden.
Dude, bash.
Warte mal, warte mal, bleib mal stehen.
Nee, vergessen.
Kann ich den segen?
Nee.
Konnte man den alten Teil nicht mit B, mit B die Säge anlassen, wenn man den Lancer
draußen hatte?
Das wäre okay mit Muni.
Alles klar.
Du hast eine Granate dran gesteckt.
Ja.
Ein bisschen Munitionsverschwendung.
Oh, hier ist eine Shotgun.
Hier ist eine Shotgun.
Ich hab keinen Platz für eine Shotgun.
Ich hab die ganze Zeit beim Überlegen, ob ich wirklich mit rechts gerannt bin.
Mit A ist man immer gerannt.
Mit A ist man gerannt.
Oh.
Ich glaube, wir müssen uns verpissen.
Ja.
Oh, oh, ich noob.
Hast du mich gerade gerannt?
Da, wo müssen wir hin?
Ach, gar nicht.
Einfach Zwischensequenz.
Okay.
Wahrscheinlich, wenn einer sterben würde, kommt der Zwischensequenz.
Wahrscheinlich.
Wir müssen jetzt Role-Playen.
Dave!
Das geht nicht.
Fake-Views.
Ja, da hast du recht.
Nochmal.
Die Untertitel sind total dumm, da steht dann Rocket Blast.
Hast du auch Tattoos?
Nee.
Wer?
Du?
Ja.
Ich hab keine.
Dafür hast du jetzt ganz viele.
Ja.
Hab ich letztens gesehen im Schrieb.
Du hast jetzt am Hals irgendwie noch, oder?
Ja.
Warum guckt der denn jetzt so, ähm, disproved, so irgendwie so?
Warum guckt der denn jetzt so, so als hätte er was angestellt?
Oh, es gibt GS.
Fuck.
Launched a Rocket.
Oh, noch mehr.
Ach so.
Halt, halt, Knopf.
Irgendwann kommt die Träne und die Rolex-Krone unterm Auge.
Omega-Lul.
Ach so.
Ach, das ist eine Rolex-Krone, die er unterm Auge hat.
Ich hab mich immer gefragt, was er unterm Auge hat.
Wer?
Montana Black.
Ach so, ja, stimmt.
Das ist eine Rolex-Krone.
Das wusste ich gar nicht.
Ich hab mich immer gefolgt.
Du wusstest nicht immer, dass das eine Krone ist?
Ich auch nicht.
Ich wusste gar nicht, was, ich wusste nicht, was es ist.
Ich hab immer gedacht, es ist irgendwie ein Fleck.
Muttermal.
Ja, sowas.
Ja, ich hab das so noch nie gezoomt gesehen.
Storytime.
Warum ist Markus eigentlich so ein Spast geworden?
Das ist dann den Markus, oder?
Der Link, klar.
Echt?
Ja.
Der war früher nie so cool, oder?
Der war früher, der war noch nie irgendwas.
Jetzt hätt er mal nicht rum.
Das ist der Schlechteste Action in der Welt.
Das ist der Schlechteste Action in der Welt
Der Schlechteste Action in der Welt.
Das ist der Schlechteste Action in der Welt.
Das ist der Schlechteste Action in der Welt